good afternoon everyone apologies um for
my lateness uh overlapping
meetings uh we'll just do a quick cut
here to kick us off and then we'll get
right into
it
hook
mod everyone did we have any
apologies looks like we're all here
today any conflicts of
interest any urgent light
business same like we are all ready to
go uh first up is first up and only up
is the notice of motion on the Main
Street trees now we have Peter did you
want to come up and
talk
try
cool
hello oh y it's
working you worshiping
counselors I've come here and I'll read
what I want to
say I would like to point out the
council should have consulted with the
business owners and R pass about
replacing trees in Main Street
this caused me to start the petition it
was clear from the petition that
business's owners wanted car
Parks 18 days later the council chose to
ignore the business owners and operators
with the notice of motion
move I am asking the the G to stop
planting the trees because there is a
major objection to Tree by the business
owners and operators affected by the
trees
while tree root boxes protect G District
Council Services they do not stop leaves
and apples falling on the foot path in
front of the shops nor will they stop
leaves fing gathers and roof and
Verandas The Simple Solution to enable
the council to properly consult with the
community is to fill the hole with
gravel to make car
pars and the gravel can be used later to
gravel roads if need
be
in support of my statement the business
operators do not want
trees I referred to you the petition
already received by the G District
Council and this latest signed list of
business owners and
operators I collected yesterday and this
morning 31 signatures and they don't
want any trees
whatsoever I would also like to point
out that just recently the chief obman
said that the council's role is to
reflect what rate payers
want I look back at the last local
elections and note that most of you
councilors stated that you would
represent the views of the r
pass and this has not happened thank you
for your opportunity to speak to the
Council on this
matter thank you for that paie
do councils have any questions for Peter
at this time uh Council
McKenzie uh thanks for coming in Peter
in your walk around over the last day or
so did you notice any major change in
the opinions of those business owners
that you were talking to though they've
got real anti now because they wasted 18
days and did nothing never consulted
anyone and they just want the trees
gone and the and the hes filled
in okay thank
you any further questions uh councilor
Reed um just a question for Mr mcroy but
initially when we spoke about these
trees going in there was a survey of
some description that was undertaken at
the time is that
correct
um the thing has been before Council
twice um at both times um
I've spoken to retailers about the
intentions of what council was doing so
um it was a letter drop in both
occasions and I've personally delivered
the letters so um
yeah there was no negative comments then
um generally people were Keen to get rid
of the problem trees which was the dawn
redwoods um and um there's been issue
with interfering with underground
services and also um you know I guess
breaking the pavement and um curban
Channel around around the trees and then
there's been been major issue with the
uh relief fall um blowing which has been
very very small blow blowing to shops um
all through the season so not not not
just not just in the winter and um again
big issues with um leaves and spouting
on front front chop front ages so um
yeah the certainly the proposed tree
that we you know we're wanting to put in
doesn't have it sort of
problem thank
you thank you councelor councilor Rich
mcf yes thank you sure your worship just
for a Peter um yeah thanks for getting
out the about talking to people uh 31
were negative uh how many were positive
there was
uh oh what's the name
the I'll tell you in a second La
hoods she didn't care if she had trees
she didn't sign the thing she didn't
care if she had trees she just wanted
them gone and the holes filled up so she
didn't care either way and there was one
other one that at the Capri she didn't
want crab apple trees if she said of any
trees she just wanted them gone too but
she said she wanted a flasher
tree and when when I asked them
originally I went around they said they
never seen anyone for 2 years from the
council to ask if they wanted trees or
not thank you thank you counselor do we
have any more questions for Mr Mr Woods
yeah yeah go for um through your hey
thanks for coming in Peter like you I've
been beating my feet and going around
talking to um U businesses I've lived on
the Main Street practically for the last
40 years working in businesses and
whatever so I know what trees are about
and everybody realizes I was against the
Redwoods as well I've asked the
businesses and I've got eight or nine
businesses are probably the same ones on
your list which have changed their minds
twice in the last fortnite um said that
they want the whole fi and trees put in
them if we're going to put trees in get
them done now they do not want any hold
it because their businesses are suffer
and they they can't do without the
parking from Christmas so the critical
thing for me was that they wanted it
done now and the bulk of them said said
to me they want if the trees are going
in get them in now and and that was the
bulk of the people I spoke to well I've
got the list here and anyone that I talk
to they just don't want trees they
should fill the holes and then consult
the people later and then yep that's
what originally wanted to do but just
didn't do that so but they definitely no
one wanted trees in they just R dead
against the trees okay there all their
names are here you can look at them no I
understand Peter I had the same thing
cuz I went around before the last
meeting and asked the same thing so I
hear what you're saying so um but I'm
just letting you know what I I found as
well thank
you thank you Council mcf any more
questions just for
Peter Council
Dixon thank you for coming in um and
addressing Council are you aware that
other towns and cities nationally and
globally uh now they don't want
utilitarian um main streets that they're
planting trees and wanting to plant more
trees no I don't know but there's plenty
of trees in G
now the center is full of
trees there's plenty there and the shops
W just parking so they can get people in
their shops to make money that's what
they're
saying thank you coun I've got all their
names here if you want to read them any
and I asked people if they wanted trees
or I give them two options I didn't just
go and say do you want it or don't I I
give them two
options thank you Peter there was only
the one shop that said thank you Peter
we'll leave it there if you if you sit
down and we'll have the debate thank you
very much for speaking really appreciate
it thank you for those questions
councelors do we want to have any
discussion on the motion at hand
did you want to go first
Aon thank you you worship um I just want
the counselors to um be aware that so
far to date the contractor has not
charged us a cent but he has cost or he
has CED a lot of flack from the res
because we have had these
delays he wants to wash his hands of it
um because he's being if for a light a
word of it bullied by the articles that
have been out in the media about what
the fees are he hasn't charged us as
scent to
date
so there just something for you to
ponder
thank you Aaron uh councelor mcdel did
you have a I had a question for Keith
about we see these new crab apple trees
they go grow really big uh I had one in
Elizabeth Street still there I think in
the house I originally was in uh can we
keep these ones if we plant them prune
small so they don't get above the the
gutters and
that yeah um just in in response to your
question yeah the um the crab apple tree
that we've chosen is is chosen for form
and shape and also that it's a medium um
small to medium tree as opposed to a
large tree and and the the comment about
the crab apples being
problematic this particular tree has a
low production of crab apples and so you
know they're not likely to be a problem
um
for retailers so yeah so you know I
think that's been thrown around as being
a I've been told it's going to attract
rice mice and um sea gos and and other
problems and it it's just it's just
fousy
really thank
you councelor
Dixon I'd like to move this motion um
not withstanding the obvious natural
capital and benefit of trees in our
urban areas the cost to rate pays and
retails through the loss of parking
space by not planting the trees until a
survey has been completed is in my view
counterproductive and quite frankly
unreasonable I therefore move the table
amended motion that in light of the
expenditure already incurred and we've
heard that it isn't but it possibly
could be the hes ex um excavated
together with the health and safety
concerns and high daily charges if as
left as is the council proceed
immediately with planting five crab
apple trees in the holes already
prepared for
planting thank you Council for the
recommendation as
tabled to we have a
seconder uh councelor Reed and we will
continue the
debate uh Council mcf thank you through
your worship I just want to know if
there's a delay if we don't pass this
motion today how long have we got you
know look what's the cost come to be and
and what is the possible timeline if we
decide we go down the track and we say
we're going to fill the holes with
gravel and or make Parks out of them
what's the delay going to be how long's
because we don't know that do
we through you your worship um the so
far with the delay we have had another
charge for a new
TMP um if we fill the holes up with
gravel that TMP still has to stay in
place because it is not a permanent
surface So currently the contractor has
been really good and hasn't charged us
for doing the site audits but that
cannot continue he cannot run a b
business without charging us and I have
strongly urged to start charging
us so just make it clear the the traffic
management plan the $300 a day would
carry on if we had gravel in there and
we're waiting to see for the survey up
to $300 a day up to $300 a day
yes so and the and the current traffic
management plan expires at the end of
the
month okay thank
you
uh councilor McKenzie and then councelor
Fraser I just like to make the comment
whichever way it goes I'll go with the
flow but I just want to be absolutely
certain that we follow correct
process in doing this with regard to
standing orders
Etc I will go with the
flow but we've got to make sure we get
it
right thank you
thank you councelor McKenzie uh
councelor Fraser and then councelor
Stringer through you worship for
speaking in favor of the motion I have
been all the way through I'm I'm well
known I do not like trees near buildings
if these are going to be kept at a
certain height I can I believe that
we're getting rid of 90% of the problems
that the other trees caused with have
five holes in the Main Street let's just
get them filled up let's get it sorted
go back and do another survey because I
don't disbelieve Keith that he went out
and spoke to the residents and the shop
owners thank you councelor Fraser
councelor
Stringer three your worship to might
make a suggestion that um if we go ahead
with um filling the holes and or putting
something in the holes that the one down
towards the public toilets be the first
one to be um completed having spoken
with the shop owner there and getting a
bit of a word in the ear about the um
loss of extra car parks and the people
needing to go to extra distance used the
public communities that we um Target
that one first thank you thank you
councel string Aon through your worship
to get the straight line of the trees to
make it all look pretty and straight we
have to start at this end and work our
way up so we've got to start with the
ones outside night and day and then move
up
and we'll try and work around it to get
that
y just further to that with the the TMP
expiring at the end of the month is the
plan if this resolution goes ahead today
that the entire set of work be completed
by the end of the month even with the
delays through you worship uh if this
resolution gets passed my understanding
is the parks team will start this week
on Friday planting the trees and we will
get them done before the TMP
expires thank you any further questions
comments Council mcdonell just one thing
Keith I thought was counted up today
there are six holes in the Main
Street um very very observant um yeah
this is probably a bonus for um
retailers but the the one outside
carnaby cars has a
um high voltage
line under where the tree hole was and
um it was unbeknown to certainly Council
um and I think power net were a bit
surprised when they saw how close to the
surface the high voltage line was um so
there that that that hole will just
become a car park we you know we we've
really got no option
one that was the one someone asked me
that making to a car so I'll get
there any further questions oh
Council my understanding was that the
council had the trees sitting in the
yard so if there's only five to go in um
was there a 63 and what's happening to
it
there is a sixth tree and we'll find a
home for it I'm
sure any further
questions no looks like it's my turn
[Music]
I'm considering the fact that the the
trees have already been bought and we're
ready to go I I have no real with the
recommendation um it's going to cost us
more money to keep those holes done and
ultimately uh if we undertake the survey
uh while it will be a painful exercise
um to remove the trees ultimately if
that is what the community want once
that survey is done we can do that um it
won't cost us that much more than what
we've already
spent that's my opinion on the motion
what I want to talk about a little bit
before we let this motion pass is how we
ended up in this situation around the
notice of motion because this extra
delay as Aaron talked about as cost as
Council well should have cost as Council
a little bit more and also the scrutiny
from the media so this is an attack on
the councilors I'm about to ask but I do
need a bit of clarification for our
community of how we got here so my first
question is councelor Dixon how come
there weren't the the onethird of the
signatures on the original notice of
motion what happened
there
I wasn't actually aware that there had
to be a third and in my apologies I
didn't go back to the standing orders
and check um I also thought there was
going to be a
report but um I take responsibility for
that thank you that glennis I really
appreciate that sorry councelor duxon um
my second is also to the chair of the
day as well or the deputy um you have
the right to refuse a notice a motion
did you were you also on the same vot as
U Council Dixon and not knowing it
needed a third as the mayor will
appreciate standing orders as a
complicated
document the provision that counselor um
Dixon quoted in her notice of motion I
believed was stand alone and override
the generality of the other provisions
and standing orders
and on that basis I was quite happy to
proceed we found out after the event in
terms of um an issue that was raised
that um either or that um uh the way
that the standing orders uh are worded
are open to
interpretation and that um that could
have been cured by a report coming with
the notice of motion or the five
signatures um I was satisfied on the day
that adequate attention had been given
to the provision to enable it to proceed
we don't always get things right
procedurally at councils and we
acknowledge that and the meeting today
is to ensure that um the correct
procedure is being followed the outcome
at the end of the day if this motion is
passed is exactly the same and I'm
comfortable with
that thank you for your honesty uh
councelor hoval uh my my only reason for
that is to make sure that we don't go
through this again um because we have
had notice a motion in the past uh both
for the removal of the Deputy Mayor and
also for uh pulling me off committees
both of those notic the motion did have
all the signatures they need so I just
want to make sure that we do follow
procedure um as we do in the past
probably a point of order here worship I
don't think we're discussing those today
I think we're actually discussing the
tree issue in regard to um you know
there's obviously a situation both
Council have explained their position I
think we should be leaving it at that
with all due respect you worship not
quite a point of order but um point
taken I was just showing that we've had
notice of motions before that have
followed
procedure that being said um the other
the other point that I want to make um
and also I'd like to thank the chief
executive for and his report um just
stating that there was meant to be
another procedure there so I do um thank
him for that too I I have a further
point of
order the matters that you referred to
were not the same
circumstances that applied in this case
in this case it was revisiting a motion
that had already been passed by Council
and therefore the provisions of standing
orders differ from the cases that you
quoted were they not notice as a motion
the circumstances are different and the
afford is open for procedures to also be
different I think that the same notice
as a motion but agreed to disagree the
counselor um just wanted to dot our eyes
and cross our teas uh the
standing order that the chief executive
related to um
24.6 which allows um him to put the
recommendation in the report um is to
consider a um an alteration to the
recommendation do we need to change it
from be amended to be
altered it's a very finicky wording but
I just don't want to be caught out
again um I think they u mean basically
the same but I'm more than happy if the
move it and wishes to amend the motion
to uh so it's in complete mirror
reflection of the term used and standing
orders which is
alteration that's fine if the move in a
second happy to have that slight
Amendment you happy with that Council
dexon I'm happy to
um to change it to be altered to the
following
thank you for that uh councelor is there
any further discussion on this matter uh
councelor
McKenzie just one point I'm a bit unsure
what now happens to the
letter that has been given to us on
Pet's behalf from David Gray and
Associates uh through your worship the
letter has already been responded to to
say this this meeting is taking place
and I've attached the report that came
to you today with with my response um
and I will for belts and braces
obviously communicate formally the
decision of the council whatever it
is thank
[Music]
you any further discussion on this
topic I will put the motion all those in
favor please say I I and against the
motion is carried that brings us to the
end of the emergency meeting thank you
everyone for
attending